hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm in coventry right now and recently
well i say recently how long have we
known each other uh for
about 12 months since i've joined the
academy like 12 months what's up dominic
did you think you'd be in one of my
videos dominic yeah
so listen camille lives in uh rugby just
outside of coventry he wanted to be a
property entrepreneur but didn't start
didn't have loads of money yes correct
so you rent properties from the landlord
and then you rent them out on a room by
room basis
now in this video we're going to do
something ridiculously unique we're
going to show you around the property
but we're also going to introduce you to
the landlord and say to the landlord why
do you let him rent it off you why don't
you rent it out yourself and you're
going to be able to see the true win-win
of rent to rent the legalities and
everything like that how many properties
do you have around this area it's
actually number four this one here so
we've got four entrants
we've got 21 rooms under ourselves right
now nice uh obviously with scope to
actually expand it financially free now
absolutely respect quit your job
absolutely so his quiz job financially
free using this strategy let's explore
rent to rents let's explore the win-win
side of rent to rent so come on take us
around the property
all right so this is the house
so the landlord then that owns this
property he's not an accidental landlord
he like specifically goes out
aggressively buys houses converts them
into hmos so this conversion
these fire doors these numbers this
furniture is this is all stuff that
you've paid for or the landlord no this
is all coming in from the landlord this
is how donald is very really
professional with specking up his
property those properties are absolutely
100 immaculate so the landlord's just
bought this he's just refurbished it
he's just paid for the fridge freezer
he's paying for all the furniture and
you
are controlling the property correct why
would the landlord give it to you
because uh i think there is a little bit
of trust here uh he knows that i'm going
to be doing a good job he wants me to
manage the properties he wants me to
take all the hassle about you know
managing the tenants right doing the
contracts we're doing all that he
doesn't have to worry about it and you
want to make this as hassle free as
possible so you've got all warranties on
everything so there's any maintenance
repairs it's all warranted the garden it
does not have grass so there's no lawn
to cut you've really systemized the heck
out of this property and you the
landlord are working together so show us
around some of the rooms then and let's
get a real feel for the figures and how
much rent you're paying and how much
rent you're getting absolutely follow me
all the rooms are with ensuite but there
is also additional bathroom downstairs
for the visitors obviously they don't
have to go into people's bedrooms okay
so you've got a little toilet for the
for the visitors there's a little bit of
storage there oh wow this is looking
sorry this is looking fabulous literally
ironing the bed i love it yeah you
ladies doing a fabulous job thank you so
so
much so this room down here how much
rent how much rent would this would this
fetch in uh that rent would probably get
about 525 525 a month that is a lot of
rent for what for a room brother it
actually is but then considering that
they don't have to pay for anything else
like bills and maintenance and even
cleaning you know that property is not
about value considering we're still in
coventry city center the other four
probably the other three properties that
you've got are they are they pretty full
yeah so out of the other three
properties i've got two rooms available
only and you've got 21 rooms now in
total yes absolutely very very very
solid very very very solid okay so
location wise in fact if we go in this
room these rooms are all very similar
location you can actually see
the coventry
university
right here oh yeah coventry university
so we're right smack bang in the center
of commentary how important is location
it's it's everything i think this is the
main reason why people are inquiring for
those that property every single day
location location location every single
room has gotten on switch
every single room has got an ensuite
every single room has got a little tv
what give me some tips when you're
showing around tenants how do you make
sure that the tenants take the room
um well i have to show them look at that
self turning on lights absolutely it
saves the lights and the electricity
because the tenants can't leave the
lights on because they just turn off the
absolute other properties haven't got
that feature and i see that on my bills
yeah nice so there's five rooms number
four number five second these rooms are
all pretty similar
now when you're showing tenants around i
assume because you've been trained well
you don't show the tenon every single
room absolutely no no no why not why not
well the thing is there's a google
saying saying that you you confuse them
you lose them i don't want to show them
every single room because they they get
almost like too much of a choice yes and
they completely lose track and they just
get confused and they just leave and
they end up not
getting the room so i just show them one
maybe two rooms at maximum because then
they can just make up their mind a
little bit faster and then yes
this is a people business it's about
sales
sales
marketing ultimately property does not
make any money the money comes from the
tenants it comes from the landlords it
comes from people so you need to be able
to sell you need to be able to market
you have to sell to the landlord should
we go find the landlord and see what's
in it for him yeah absolutely let's go
and see him so profit wise how much you
making on this property
the minimum profit i'm going to be
making on this property will be 500
pounds expect i'm expecting a little bit
more but that's crazy because most
people don't make that much money on a
property that they've bought so you're
making more money than most landlords
but you how much money did you have to
put into this property well technically
i didn't put down anything yet because
the agreement i had with the landlord is
when the property is completely taken
from the builders and everything is
sorted and i move in the tenants this is
why i start paying the rent so you've
not started paying right now no but
you're already moving tenants in
absolutely
let's find out what's in it for the
landlord let's talk to the landlord
a few moments later
so i hope you don't mind me filming no
no
i've been in front of a camera many
times all right good so you're the
you're the owner of this property
question is what what made you decide to
pass this on to camel under his control
so he can manage it and take care of
everything why didn't you just do it
yourself
um i
don't have the time it's the honest
answer
i find the build process stressful
enough and in order to then take on the
tenant aspect of it uh generate
contracts make sure that everything's
compliant yeah so what made you trust
camille why did you have all the people
you could have passed a property onto
why did you choose camille i i think
that i've got a good sense of judgment
in terms of um
in terms of deciding whether someone has
got the right sort of approach the right
um
integrity professionalism etc in order
to take the job on and uh camille ticked
many if not all of the boxes right so i
mean again if you chose to if you manage
this yourself and you did the work you
got the tenants of course you'd have
more money in your pocket yes but then
you'd have less time exactly so for you
it's just a case of an easier life what
are you hoping to see then in this
business relationship what would be a
great outcome for you um
a stress-free relationship i i'm still
very
just in my nature very
uh keen to assist camilla if he ever
needs the assistance in terms of
maintenance or whatever it may be but
you know it's just being able to pick up
the phones of one person and have the
property uh know that the property's in
hand
and been dealt with accordingly um to
regulations by law yeah and
and yeah just being able to sort of sort
of um
feel comfortable about uh
about owning the property but it being
rented to quality tenants yeah um with
everything in place well i think you've
got the right man for the job because
camille's got three other properties
that are going really well and i hope it
works out thanks for letting us film and
stay tuned
very much you're very welcome